you have such a um such an interesting
life
you know meeting your brother michael
and your guys happen to be doing the
same stuff
and your acclaim too you know you guys
are both on top of your game and
how's that feel you know it's amazing
because um
back in the 80s you know when you were
lighting up the ring and cover sports
illustrated i'm following you like
there's no tomorrow and all the other
great boxers of the era because that was
the one of the greatest errors in boxing
that was really amazing no no
no they were magical that's the magical
magical every week we saw the best fight
the best right
and i'm a huge boxing fan my dad was
teaching me boxing as a kid
right out of the womb we're watching
boxing on saturdays you know why world
of sports
and it was boxing every week boxing
boxing boxing out comes this man
very handsome debonair james bond
looking
dressed to the nines brought a whole new
flare to the world of announcing
and i became a huge fan but i had an
issue because every time he came out
and they flashed his name on the screen
it said michael buffer
i used to own telemarketing companies in
my 20s right and this is before the
internet
and like we all did back then when
you're in another town you look in the
phone book you see it there's a tyson
you see if there's a buffer or whatever
i never saw my last name in a phone book
in any city in the united states and
here's this man
you know michael buffer and i'm like wow
what's going on i started getting this
weird feeling in my
stomach so i'm calling don king's
offices bob aaron i'm trying to get a
little more information on the man about
six months pass and people are coming up
to me is getting more popular and say
hey is that your brother
michael buffer the guy that goes let's
get ready to rumble and i'm like
no my brother's brian who i grew up with
my whole life
so long story cut short my dad and i are
taking a road trip up to san francisco
one day and i'm like dad
i'm telling the same thing i'm telling
you people are coming up to me it's
almost daily now
because boxing's the water cooler
conversation on a monday after the
weekend fights
and i said dad do you have any idea who
this is and i got this mike
i think that's your brother yeah the
hell of a dude
what i'm like 29 years old i'm like are
you kidding me
and he said well son i never told you i
and he never told me he was married
briefly um
when he was around 20 it was during
world war ii
he was called overseas to do his part in
the war he came back
a child was born a divorce ensued and
the last time he saw the child i think
was when he was two and a half years old
and you know it's one of those stories
that happens right and so lo and behold
uh michael was raised by foster parents
i know he explained that to you when he
was on his
your podcast before um under the name of
huber
and when he went in the army at around
20 during the vietnam era
they said your birth certificate says
you're michael buffer you're not michael
huber
right and he had great great parents
that raised him and he they stabbed him
it's like you're michael buffer
and had that not happened we wouldn't be
sitting around in this conversation
right now wow so that's one of those
forks in the road that happens in life
so he was doing a an event out here
at a small venue uh that the gooses used
to put their fights on in the valley
that's no longer around
and i my brother brian are watching the
fights with him tonight and we said dad
why don't you call
leave a message see if he'll call you
back so my dad did
michael called back they got together
for lunch turned out to be his
his son right now i'm like i again i
might not have this age
exactly correct but i'm like 29
michael's in the area of 43 you know
there's a 13-year difference and
uh with that being said we got together
for dinner as a family after they had
that lunch they got along
very very well and in walks i'll never
forget this night in walks michael
looking as amazing as he always looks
i'm a huge fan
and like okay i'm a fan but now this is
my blood this is my
brother walking in i can't even begin to
tell you what that felt like
and we got along great we all got along
great and
from then on with the companies i owned
i had two companies
you know successful making the money
beach house living the life the whole
bit
but i was traveling and i would go to
vegas i would go to new york i would i
would stop in to see the fights michael
and i would have dinner we'd go out
together
1992 evander holyfield riddick bow one
at the thomas and max sold out so i'm in
the audience and i'm watching everybody
going crazy when michael's doing let's
get ready to rumble i mean you've got
nicholson jumping up and holding
going nuts and everybody's just going
nuts right and this light bulb went off
in my head because i've been a marketer
and a brand or you know a businessman
before i'm an announcer my whole life
owning a number of different companies
i went back to my room that night
instead of going out and partying and
playing blackjack and all the stuff we
love to do and we're in vegas
and i sat down and i couldn't stop mike
i just kept writing like three pages of
notes
like trademark this five words properly
you know
protect it uh keep the boxing ring as
his base like the hbo box
ring especially branch them out put them
in every form of sports and
entertainment there is
movies ready to rumble tv shows thinking
video games toys
you know thinking all the stuff that can
be done and i just couldn't stop it's
like i'm just sitting there and i'm just
going like this
so i contacted michael again long story
cut short i basically in
so many words said michael i i want to
make you richer and more famous than you
ever dreamed
hopefully myself in the process i'm
willing to sell my two companies
i'm burned out i'm not passionate about
what i do anymore because i live my life
on passion everything i do i do with
passion
right and i had this passionate moment
thinking what i could do with him is his
partner
and i said let's the best thing to do
here is i want to become
your manager right and also want to
become your partner
because not only do i want to help you
get in every form of sports and
entertainment
take these five words put it on the tip
of everybody's tongue make it part of
american culture
i called it the clarion call to the pure
integrity of the competitive spirit that
was my term for let's get ready to
rumble like
you know every time you hear it it's
like we got to go out and do our thing
right
and michael in so many words said how
are you going to do it and i said
i don't know but if i'm going to give
all this up you better believe i'm gonna
make this happen
lo and behold uh became his manager
became partners
started working it due to his brilliant
ability to perform and do everything he
does so well i mean let's face it he's
legendary the greatest announcer of all
time
right there's no question and i say that
with complete respect and love for my
brother
and um it just went on and it caught on
and everything started catching and the
first product i have i would go to trade
shows
you know around the country and i would
make i go to kinkos and make these promo
kits
they cost me fifteen dollars a kit back
then because you know everything was
different back then
and i'd stock up on them and i'd walk
the floors and i'd shake hands and take
names and i'd see products that would be
great with let's get ready to rumble on
it and i pitched to people on it
and i was just an animal i go to the
boxing events and i'm shaking hands and
taking names and
making appearance deals for him any way
i can and things that come across
michael's desk he's handing me to take
care of for him
and it just started building and within
a year our first product was a talking
key chain
right it was a boxing glove when you
press the button of course let's get rid
of your rumble came out of it right
and there was also a mug you know that
had like a football on it
for football and you watched football
and you pressed the button and drinking
i said let's get ready to rumble that
was our first two products
and then it just started taking off and
our big hit was the ready to rumble
boxing video game
if you ever played video games it came
out in the house yeah yeah
and when we came out with the ready to
rumble boxing video game in the first 24
hours along with nine other games that
were released with the dreamcast
system uh combined it did like 97.1
million dollars in sales
in 24 hours right which has been
surpassed since then by call of duty and
all that
but it was either variety or hollywood
phenomenon yeah it was phenomenal
yeah phenomenal yeah exactly and we're
just you know it's like we're making
entertainment and sports history here as
we go along and it just started feeding
my fire
you know and i just kept going and i
sold the two companies i quit with the
money i had in the bank because
sometimes you just got to go for it
right which you know better than anybody
and you know better than anybody
it's taking what i call the puncher's
chance so we went for it
and it just all worked out beautifully
michael and i we get along great
it's it's teamwork it's total teamwork
he does what he does
i'm the man behind the man behind the
rumble you know the sheriff of the
rumble the man behind the rumble
but michael's the talent it's michael's
he did it he created it and it's just a
beautiful story
something that we both take away from
the business and the brains
is it safe to say the business in their
brains take a business and a brand you
know it's just i saw it i realized where
it could go
and i just wanted to put everything i
could into it to do what i told him i
was going to do which make him richer
and more famous in the evergreen
[Music]
you